I'm assuming that's why my opponent
chose this name but who knows maybe
there's just a puzzle freak a puzzle
maniac so I did that uh okay what did I
do
I was gonna go for a bad vinick's set up
with that h3 g4 idea that I did in the
one game but let's not let's go with
something else
and she's trying to get in d4 recently
from that Norway tournament we saw this
opening I think it was Carlsen versus
raja baath not the same variation though
we had things being quite symmetrical up
to move six or seven all right so what
to do about this pawn tension I could be
grabbing some space
d5 it's night off to find a new home I'm
not so sure about d6 in that position so
how do I recapture I recaptured the pawn
if my opponent is going to be playing d5
they're doing so it's got to be a bad
version of some opening right he already
took one step so pawn takes is d5 really
gonna be good probably not my opponent
is still needs a couple moves before
there devourer King site castled one two
three moves so position opens up it's
likely to be favoring me hmm Wow
now that's different okay so pawn takes
pawn takes Queen takes King takes is
otherwise I'm winning upon on e5 I don't
think that's a good idea I'm gonna go
for this hang on
yeah with he doesn't have a good home
without black having a C pawn up on c6
my knight could be jumping into either
of these two squares you both have
support points this pawn supporting them
so pin the knight queenside castle with
check looks good let me do that although
no you know what maybe I should have
considered a bit more something like
Knight here for a fork and if the King
moves then my another Knight comes over
and looks at this but then I always have
to contend with Bishop here depending my
knight I want to be able to castle get
out of the pin if Bishop before is
played castle with check and then jump
in my jump into d5 alright the castle
first
and there's bishops in a pin
hmm 95 Knight takes pawn takes Bishop
takes Bishop would be a losing move
because I recapture and I'm my pawn
would be threatening the knight and my
night would be threatening f7 so 95 9
takes pawn takes the knight has to move
immediately and then I could take the
bishop and then the pawn and go for that
Knight takes Knight pawn takes he's
isolated see file has opened up rook c8
come with check night before maybe I
could play a three maybe I could play
King b1 and actually I don't like King
b1 Bishop f5 stuff maybe after night
before if Knight takes pawn takes Knight
before maybe I don't do anything but
just capture the bishop with check and
then capture the pawn if Knight takes
pawn with check maybe I run towards the
center with my king I'm not sure who
stands better here I think the game
could be decided in these next couple
moves and well take that Bishop they
takes Bishop Bishop takes Knight
interesting move okay
I don't know if I'm really getting
anything now
I'm going to take that dark square
bishop pomp takes Bishop I take this
night with check these pawns then become
split and I follow up by winning upon on
g5 so King takes their still in a pin I
have to do something my dark square
Bishop I back up maintain the pin or do
I run in this direction looking at c5
and watching over d4 the pivot point for
this night I like this I don't I don't
think maintaining this pin is anything
great g5 bishop g3 I'm hitting this pawn
I don't know I don't think it's so great
maybe then there's 94 if there's a
couple captures here Knight f2 occurs
with the fork so I'm just looking at
Bishop c5 check
I'd love to force this King to the
eighth rank prior to this rook getting
involved but it's being watched over and
maybe I could still do this very tempted
to do that but maybe I should secure my
dark square Bishop special yeah I want
to I want to hang on to my dark square
Bishop Knight g4 stuff I want to rule
out I don't think there's any rush but
now I think I go forward with this put
pressure on this pawn there is no push
so I think it has to be supported still
quite uncomfortable
I think the rook maybe it was a mouse
slip or maybe black was intending and
watching over this but I think rook here
would have been better so that when this
position presents itself if there is a
check on c5 that King could have always
dropped back to e8 and been a bit more
comfortable but now we have if I take
the pawn there's a check discover check
with the knight King here Bishop check
bishop block Bishop takes rook takes
pawn for let's not do that King here
night before is of quite annoying
hmm you know a three might be a good
move do a three but the idea here being
what pawn takes Bishop takes with check
and also just be for to reinforce this
point however Knight here might be good
mmm
I think that's quite all right or is it
no it's not dropping app on iPhone this
down to minute Knight takes bishop takes
or that
well
yeah dropping upon well let's just get
out of that is there any compensation at
all
rook takes if paan takes I could play
here is pawn is hit twice do that
however bishop in ouch ouch that'll hurt
me Bishop here would have been a giant
pest Bishop check King here what do i do
then
nothing right here right here is gonna
be a monster well look at this support
point on d3 I'm down upon my opponents
in a better position the only thing I
have is time as usual yes lovely spot
lovely lovely spot
well
let's take this I have to try and break
this stuff down to break this this pawn
up Bishop check now let me grab a pawn
back actually who I shouldn't have done
that
no maybe it's alright where is it yeah
if there was an eventual pawn takes pawn
takes I have a Brooke check worse I
think
let's do this I'm not even sure why why
did I do that defend this pond
okay I got a take here and then here
next the rook is attacked I'm actually
better now this bishop box is up tonight
the rook is hit attack that pond
I should just taken upon another night
that was stupid
let's get this guy rolling get behind
him and then push connected passed pawns
my king could stop this pie just in time
and my pond advances the other one kicks
the rough from the blockading square no
time good game good good game let's back
up flip oh man what could I have done
better I wonder it well what kind of my
opponent done better I thought I had a
good position when I have the bishop
hair and then I think within those next
couple moves tables turned and my
opponent became better I wonder about
this d6 both one of six is better to
eventually establish a pawn on d5
because now you've run the risk of me
having a strong center with d5 I wonder
if e 6 is something a bit better I think
that's something to look into I don't
know that this could be correct
is this still book it's okay to really
go and castle it doesn't seem correct
maybe it is I'm definitely not good at
the openings knowing the theory and
stuff be 5 yeah I don't know
coins come off I think this has to be
good for me they could be doing
something different than the bishop both
oh no I get my bishop out it's got to be
something better here my opponent was
wise not to take my knight I think
unless he could get away with Knight
takes and the night before stuff against
my king and the bishop coming out on the
F file around the f5 square on this
diagonal that might have been something
Knight takes Knight I can't do Bishop
takes Bishop the night would recapture
I'm down a piece on Knight takes pawn
takes Knight before it could be quite
problematic for me there's less what one
thing you could be saying to yourself as
black is if you're going to take this
knight in white captures with the pawn
you have less concern about your own
king that white pawn on the D file will
act as a shelter let's have a question
I dropped back I secured my bishops
position maybe this is just not correct
maybe I should play it a bit slower get
my King out for this file or maybe a 3 B
4 King B 2 is better I could play King B
1 getting it off the file but I run into
more annoying things like Bishop f5 so
maybe maybe this is a slight improvement
for me to not play c5 just yet there's
no rush maybe I could play it a little
bit slower and look into eventually
grabbing some more space with my 3/2 to
majority I don't think that there's any
rush I'm a single move away from being
fully developed maybe a 3 B 4 King B 2
is best Bishop e2 maybe a couple of
rooks come off and then my lights grab
my bishop hair could do something maybe
c5 was just not so great rook c8 and now
I have some concern of these discovered
checks with in connection with Bishop f5
stuff I have to be quite careful yeah
it's going astray for me now I'm down
upon so I think maybe this was a better
setup instead of c5 my suggestion that I
have for myself is a 3b for my opponent
did well to punish this quick c5 will
bite I'm pretty sure I can't do much
about it I'm getting pushed around and
when it gets to this point right here
how can my opponent do better I think I
dodged a great bullet here bishop
pinning the knight our way excuse me
instead of the pawn push Bishop ends the
night and that is a difficult situation
get out of Bishop takes pawn you could
just take the bishop you're taking my
rook for free I'm in big trouble after
Bishop a4 I think we were both under a
minute at that point but that's my quick
suggestion at least when it comes to
tactical shots that were available
during the game and then
again at the earliest point maybe
there's a different decision on this
move one two three
this fourth move maybe e6 with d5 and
then you don't have to worry about your
night position on c6 he could be secure
okay
good game jigsaw 82